Uh,
no.
Say,
uh,
Paul,
[inaudible] Burke,
Cornell,
uh,
man,
I've been studying Indonesian for six
months and 17 days and I still can't
introduce myself.
What's going
and Andrea.
Hi Guys.
This is Paul.
Today I want to talk to you about one of
the most important elements of learning
a language of studying a language.
And that is consistency.
This is one of my mottos is consistency
is king.
If you read my blog or something you've
ever talked to me about languages,
you probably heard me say that slogan,
that model,
the consistency is king.
Uh,
the people who really get good at
languages are the people who study
consistently.
They study every day come hell or high
water.
They don't find excuses to skip the
studying.
The people who don't really learn as
much,
the people who,
Ooh,
don't get that good that people would
learn just a bit.
Um,
those are the people who just study
whenever,
right?
I feel like it,
the people who don't study consistently,
they just study based on a whim.
So I like to think about consistency in
a couple of ways.
The first way is like this,
um,
your language ability is like a bucket
with a small hole in the bottom,
right?
Uh,
so the water,
the liquid inside is your language
ability and if you stopped studying,
then there's a slow leak and your
ability will slowly diminish if you
don't talk about the bucket.
But if you top up the bucket every day
by studying,
then you can maintain the level,
uh,
consistently.
You can maintain a certain level or even
raise the level of the liquid inside the
bucket.
But it's when you stop studying,
when you're not consistent,
then gradually day by day,
each day a little bit of the liquid
leaks out the bottom and the level
diminishes.
So that's like your language ability
going down.
So if you've ever studied a language for
a couple months and then you took a few
weeks off,
like maybe you just lost motivation or
whatever,
then you came back to it.
You probably noticed if you probably
felt that you had lost the majority of
what you had learned.
Right?
Uh,
so that's because you had that little
bit of liquid in the bucket.
And then it gradually mostly leaked out.
There was probably some residue in
there,
a few drops,
but you probably lost a lot of the meat
of what you had learned.
So,
um,
it's one,
uh,
one example.
Uh,
you,
if you've ever been a couple of years
into studying a language like a year or
two,
and then you took a few weeks off,
you probably noticed that your level had
diminished a bit.
Probably it had gone down,
but you probably didn't feel like you
lost most of what you've learned because
it's that gradual diminishment is that
gradual lowering of the level.
It's a slow leak.
So the more of a beginner you are,
uh,
the more of your ability you will lose
if you're not consistent.
Uh,
but the way to always maintain your
level and to keep increasing it is to be
consistent and top up the bucket every
day.
So that's one way I like to think about
your consistency of and studying.
The other way I like to think about it
is,
uh,
in terms of investing,
when you invest money over time,
uh,
when you do it consistently,
you can gain compound interest,
right?
Uh,
that means that you make interest on the
money that you invest,
but then you make interest on the
interest as well.
Uh,
this is similar to a phenomenon that
I've noticed when studying consistently.
When you study every day consistently
and you don't take days off,
you're learning kind of takes on a life
of its own and you end up learning more
than you would expect from the amount
you're studying.
Right?
Um,
that's partly because just your brain is
learning,
uh,
in the off time when you're not
studying,
it's kind of processing things in the
background all day.
Uh,
but basically if you are consistent,
then you can get your,
your learning to sort of critical mass
where it starts to take on a life of its
own and you learn more than you would
have if you had studied that same number
of days.
But with breaks in between.
So it's really important to,
um,
to always keep investing on a daily
basis,
investing regularly so they could,
you can get that compounding effect in
your learning.
Okay.
So that's another way I like to think
about it.
So there's the,
the bucket with a hole in the bottom,
but then there's compounding interest.
There's those two ways.
So the most important point is study
every day.
Be Consistent.
Also put in a certain amount of time
everyday.
Try to commit as much time to it as you
can.
But more important than that is to do it
consistently every day.
How do you be consistent?
That's the question that remains.
A lot of people intend to be consistent,
but they end up taking a lot of time,
often being inconsistent.
So those people usually are taking
action based on how they feel at the
moment.
They wake up in the morning and they
think,
oh,
I'm tired today.
A screw it.
I just want to study today.
Uh,
they're basing their actions on the
feeling of that moment,
which is something you can't really
control.
I mean,
the way you feel depends on all sorts of
different factors out of your control.
It depends on maybe what you ate
yesterday.
It depends on the weather.
It depends on how well you slept,
depends on stress at work,
all these things.
Uh,
so you can't really control it that
easily unless you're always monitoring
all those things really closely.
So the way to,
the way to take action should be based
on your vision for your outcome,
what you want to get out of learning
that language.
And also based on just the commitment,
a commitment to achieving that outcome,
achieving that vision.
So let's say you want to be a French
English translator.
That's your dream.
So you have to have that vision in mind
for the future,
that goal,
what will that look like?
And then a commitment to work hard every
day to achieve then,
right?
So then in that case,
if you have that vision and commitment
when you up in the morning and you're
tired or you're hung over or whatever,
then you will just tell yourself,
okay,
I don't feel like it today,
but I have that vision.
And the commitment.
So I'm going to do it anyway because
it's not based on the feeling.
So that's how you,
that's how you can be consistent is by
doing that.
All right.
Don't let it be based on a feeling.
A feeling is changing by the moment.
It's out of your control.
A base it on your vision and commitment.
All right.
Hope that's helpful.
Thank you very much for listening and
talk to you,
right?
Yeah.